what's been happening this week uh
obviously probably the first thing we
have to talk about
is probably the top G release
did you would you not say
yeah that was a surprise that came out
definitely saw that in the feed and I
was like whoa okay
there was no leading up to it really or
no murmurs about that coming up yeah
it was certainly a bit of a shock but uh
there were some predictions made by some
people so it's good that he's moving
taking a step forward in the right
direction
and uh getting more of his freedom back
but it's still a bit of a shame that
they stole it from him my son is my son
is off an Australia on vacation with his
mom and I told him he got released he
said it was the best in AC dot that's
good
pubg is on South Park too when they
first brought him in the frame I'm like
are they trying to do Andrew Tate there
and then he came back later in the show
and they gave him a different name like
oh the Romanian human trafficker and I
was like ah it's pretty funny sorry did
they incorporate him into a South Park
episode
yeah he didn't he only had a few seconds
of air time though he was uh they're on
spring break Randy wanted a bunch of
hoes to come over to have like a real
spring break party and uh he's like hey
we need more people for the party and
the the pimp was uh Andrew Tate but they
gave him some weird name oh okay
all right we'll set it up this way it
looks like the white the white screen's
better
um might be one or two others that pop
into
looks like mops at the gym so
um what else was on the uh trending this
week uh obviously the biggest news I
guess Andrew getting house arrest which
seems like [__] news but it's actually
better than sitting in a jail cell
rotting in a [__] cubicle right yeah
I think I I think between him
Trump and Douglas McKay getting found
guilty of making a meme in 2016. and I'm
not sure if you guys it just confirms to
me about the Matrix you know we sounded
like conspiracy theorists two years ago
and now it's
um I don't know if you saw the a lady
who done something very similar to
Douglas McKay she set up a fake
pro-trump account and told Trump borders
to go abroad and by text
um nothing happened to her whereas this
guy is facing five to ten years in jail
for making a meme yeah rules for thee
not for me that's how it goes isn't it
yeah that sounds about right yeah sounds
about right so you know whether it's you
know you know no matter where you are
aligned politically The Matrix is there
it protects itself and it doesn't want
people uh breaking out of the Matrix and
you know I told my son I said the only
reason they went after Andrew Tate was
uh because he was unplugging kids high
school kids like my son from The Matrix
they need him plugged in
yeah it's I mean I get it it's uh
it's an unfortunate reality of the world
today is you have to muffle your
opinions and ideas because
what like 50 years ago you could say
whatever you want in a room now if you
say say things that they that they don't
like because of the internet and because
of amplification it can spread far and
wide so this is how they handle you well
it started from people getting easily
offended right so that's yeah that's
where it started I don't really have to
defend these arguments with facts or
logic they just feel offended and then
they can cancel you or they can punch a
Nazi and suddenly violence is
justifiable and when people widely start
to accept that premises then uh I mean
the state will take advantage of that
I watched interesting documentary lately
that I found on Netflix and I think I
had my VP on VPN on I think it's on the
US Netflix too is there a baby there you
guys you guys you guys having a kid uh
here's Journey baby um no that was my uh
that was my ringtone somebody was trying
to call me but oh that'll get your
attention
but uh I was watching a doc I think it
was last night that I watched it it was
on Netflix it's the uh Abercrombie and
Fitch doc if you remember that brand and
me as a marketing guys like oh this
would be really interesting and my
brother and I worked there a bit in like
high school my first year of college so
I thought that would be a throwback
it'll be funny you know it was a very
interesting brand back in the day for
those who remember it and and really at
the end of it all I got it was obviously
a Netflix production so it was like
really littered with kind of woke stuff
and as the doc went on it became more
and more woke but the very end all I
realized like okay a bunch of a bunch of
woke whiny people killed a brand because
it targeted a demographic that they
didn't agree with and all these people
had come on they're like yeah I'm in
charge of like the Asian comedians
Alliance of North America or oh I'm in
charge of like Black Entertainment
whatever and then they come on like well
Abercrombie we don't like them because
it targets uh good-looking young white
guys in college and I was just thinking
that's kind of that's kind of the
weirdest thing I don't really care now
I'm a little too old for the brand
anyways I looked it up and it looks like
every other brand out there now I'm like
oh are they still around yeah they are
they're just irrelevant now
have you heard a big marketer behind
that brand
yeah have you heard go ahead have you
heard of the brand FUBU f-u-b-u yeah
yeah I mean yeah they're the exact same
I mean what what what's wrong with that
you know people you know people have
have looks of different looks this isn't
for me I'm like okay then don't [__]
wear it yeah exactly you know
I mean you know Charles is keeping the
waste called industry alive all on his
own
it's like oh it's for a bunch of preppy
young white kids and then some fat chick
with a label down there like a group she
represents that clearly discriminates
I'm like okay can't can't you make your
own bread do you have to have everything
do we have to be putting fat people and
fit people clothes and I make this
complaint too because back when I was
fat it was really hard to find clothes
and then once I became fit I'm like I
actually liked Brands like Abercrombie
because it was a bit wider in the
shoulders and it kind of tied around the
bicep and tapers in on the sides it's
not flowy for like every other brand out
there it's for fat people and uh so I
kind of dug the brand for a little bit
when I was like 18 19. it was a
children's brand back in the day but
I was sitting there watching this trying
to trying to remember and and I'm
thinking do you guys have to have
everything do you have to destroy
everything they're trying to cancel
friends now I saw in the memes because
that's where I get my news like friends
that show is pretty innocuous
uh it's today it would be considered too
offensive for some people and even back
then there's some folks that have blamed
friends for the softening for the
general softening of the West which is
it which is interesting because I saw
something this morning where Jennifer
Aniston said that they wouldn't be able
to do a version of friends today because
we've been too offensive but criticize
friends as being one of the pivotal
points in history that is uh softened
you know the Western you know such a
sense because really the guys in the
show like even
um even Joey as much of a player he was
portrayed to be in the show wasn't that
masculine of a dude he was still kind of
like
or wet noodles like fart
yeah
so but no no Rich two with serious
points um one a guy once said he who was
sober in the Nightclub at 2 am as king
and he who was anyway masculine in
today's modern society can also be king
yeah because you know if we all go back
to when we were all plugged in and when
we were all trying to I remember this in
the 90s
um and you know you're you probably
remember it too rich the younger guys
don't put this whole new man there was a
new man kind of on the scene who could
do cooking and cleaning and all this
[__] and it was just kind of becoming a
soft subservient type of dude and it was
encouraged and I can remember when we
were plugged in we were all trying to do
that because we thought that's what
women wanted and then Chad would come
along and just take the women right from
under her nose yeah I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out